Chucky's show with how Rudnick hey
everybody did you watch all the new
movie trailers this weekend they're
peppered throughout that big football
thing that people were watching I hope
you got your fill of Spock the rock
zombies that flock all while watching
jocks and your undies and socks I'm
taking a poetry class and learning at it
let's go through those trailers and rate
them on a scale from very good to Oz the
great in power first up we have the
trailer for star trek into darkness
shall we begin seeing of treks into
darkness out that 34 minute blackout
even Janet Jackson's nipple was
embarrassed for you in New Orleans this
seems like a great warm-up for JJ Abrams
real movie star wars yeah I said it but
I do like that the guy with the best
name in the business is in the movie
Benedict Cumberbatch because that I'm
giving this trailer to Vulcan salutes I
can't do it good World War Z this was
Brad Pitt's best work since his perfume
commercial but you know what this
trailer actually looks pretty awesome
what is this what the trailer is nothing
like the book trailer sucks
seriously guys get it together it's like
if I just took the name Catcher in the
Rye and made a movie but instead of
having Holden Caulfield or placing a
bunch of bulls to give this movie two
severed zombie thumbs down now let's
look at Disney's newest ride I mean
movie The Lone Ranger let's see a weirdo
Johnny Depp Helena Bonham Carter
obviously directed by Gore Verbinski Tim
Burton know about this guy's be careful
otherwise Burton might get revenge by
writing a new film about a misfit whose
friends went off and played without him
I give the Lone Ranger of one
unflattering racial stereotype and then
there was fast and furious 6 starring
the rock and bizarro The Rock seriously
though
Vin Diesel is kind of like the sucky The
Rock right let's say they're elements
okay the rock is gold
rocks also in this movie snitch he's in
this cool movie about Bill is it too
soon to call the year of the rock The
Fast and Furious trailer looks pretty
badass and I give the rock infinite
rocks they told me they were gonna be a
bunch of rocks right now Iron Man 3 how
many in the air Jarvis 13 uh way too
short what happens in this movie where's
Pepper Potts is gwyneth back or she
hanging out with Coldplay just Thor show
up what about this guy is he gonna be
around America wants to know is Hawkeye
gonna be there damn it you guys
I give Iron Man to schwannomas just
needed to see more identity thief also
aired a trailer during the Superbowl
I was pretty intrigued by it so I sat
down with the film stars to do some
weird stuff so guys I was hoping today
we could assume identities of like
people who are really in the public eye
right now sure Manti Te'o and his fake
girlfriend
hi I'm responsible for the biggest
non-story that ever was I don't but you
sounded so pretty on the phone where
have you been all this time why haven't
you supported him during this difficult
time ah that makes total sense people
are saying you you were actually a dude
could be true wait now I hear it
Osama bin Laden and Jessica Chastain
she's so pretty she's incredible she's
magical you're incredible right I could
I keep this on afterwards yes the
strength Osama was zero dark thirty
accurate yeah I'm dead as Osama oh
that's that's the scene in zero dark
thirty we were waiting for ya Osama
there's more newest pictures of you
watching TV in your compound
what were your shows funds Bob so it was
silver spoons
and Hogan's life family you dumb
redheaded cow you found bin Laden you
solve the greatest mystery can you solve
the mystery of what Tree of Life was
about no one knows no one knows wanna
see that was great that was awesome you
guys my thanks to the cast check that
movie out listen Makar
she's a boss back to the Super Bowl what
about Beyonce's halftime show I think
she held her business like a boss what
was the most epic halftime show ever be
though tell us in the comments below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt then you're gonna be walking
around looking like a boss that's all I
got I'm out running bye bye